(whispering) Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier,
and welcome back to Outlast 2.
Now, I'm whispering, because we seem to be stuck in a closet (Wouldn't be the first time)
and I don't know exactly where we're going to end up.
But we might still be in the uUOOhuuggh
Well!
Of all the places I expected to be, this wasn't it...
But! We've got a message here.
(reads note)
Oooh, Papa Knoth! You're such a big ol' softie! (;
So kind to your congre-
(Scared mark:) AUUUUUUEYHHHHHH!!
Well! Just gonna go-
AAAAAYYY!!
Uhhh, OH!
I should do this!
No, I can't do that, I should go in here!
No I can't do that...
We believe in you mark...
wuOAH! Yes I can!!!
He won't have ANY IDEA where I went because I'M such a SNEAKY PERSON! (Not)
Hello?
Helloo??
(quietly) Hello?
I can't peek outta here,
so it's either all or nothing.
(nervous laughing)
Okay, alright then.
Well!
oOOOOo
Jeezums!!!
What are you doing?!
What are you doing?!?!
And why are you doing it???
There's really no need for any of this, you can be a lot-
LESS!!
oOOUUUUHMYGOD
OHMYGOD
OHMYGODOHMYGODOHMYGODOHMYGODOHMYGODOHMYGODOHMYGOD
OOOHOOHOOHOOOOO
Alright then!
Well!
I think-I think- I think I have a funny feeling he knows I'm here... (Most definetly)
Which is good a-
WOOOOHOOHOOHOOHOOHOOOOO!!
HO-KAY
I see a backway, I'm gonna go that way.
HEEEEEEEEE
Okay, I'm gonna get this battery first.
HABOINK!
Okay, off we go!
I don't know why he can't get-
OOOOHH woah...
ooh
Hello.
No, not that..
Oh! Hi! Euuugh!
I don't know why I wanted to see that.
Also this weird arrow floating in mid-air is cool.
But apparently...
ooh
So I think we gotta sneak through these woods while dodging these arrows,
which always is a fun excursion.
But I'm gonna try not too waste to many batteries here because-...
ooohh
I mean, it gave me some!
oOOoh
What the fuck was that???
oh mah gadh
oHH mAH GADH
Okay, so th-
(scared Markimoo inhales)
Okay, it's fine.
I don't know why,
but he's being really, REALLY, restless today..
Okay.
I can't hear any of em',
and I don't know where they are,
which means that I probably gotta sneak around.
Now I don't know exactly how I got to be in THIS juncture...
Because I could've sworn that I came in from another cabin,
and all of a sudden,
he's being a little bit of a-
wHYYYY can I hide in a tree stump?
I don't think I wanna hide in there!
Think I wanna try to sneak through this!
Euugh.
yeeEE!
Oh man, I'm just chew-
oOOOOH HI!!
OHHH HI!!
WHY ARE YOU IN THE WOODS?!?
Why are you in the woOOods?
Oh boy.
Okay.
Alright.
UH OH
Okay. We're fine.
Fine-
OHHH no
Oh wait, I don't need light here!!
It's frickin'...
AH
frickin' bright as SHIT!
Okay,
but there's some-
OOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOH HI!!
Oh, THAT'S the big guy!
Oh, that is most definitely the big guy and he is right there,
he has not moved.
He has not moved a MUSSHLE.
So I gotta find a way..
to SNEAK-SNACK!
AROUND HIM!
Aaaaaalrighty then!
Ok, I think I can go through the right side,
because he seems to be delegated over THEAAUHHHH!
Now I'm gonna go over here where there's dead bodies and flies!
GREAT!
Okay.
Euugh!
He's over there...
I think I see a light in the distance, that's either him-...
AUUGH!
I forgot that there might be someone in front of me over here!
Oh, he's comin' this way.
Okay.
So- aaAAAHH I see you big guy, I see you big guy, okay.
Just don't come this way and we're gonna have a good ol' time.
We're gonna have a GREAT time.
YRRRRGH
ALSO it's been brought to my attention by you guys that I need to check more of my recordings...
Uh, I kinda learned that after the last one that I found in the dream world...
was garbled and backwards...
And there might be a hidden message in all of those things, but...
Don't have time to think about that right immediately.
Okay.
yeee
Okay!
We're fine.
HOOO BOY!
HOOOOO BOYYYY
Can I lock that?
Yes I can!
Hokay-
NOOOO!!!
Okay, don't do that-
Yeah, do THIIIIS!
That's the SMART maneuver!
Too bad that guy's
duAAOAAOAAOAAO
THERE'S TWO DOORS!
Who would've thought there would've been two doors?
M'kay.
So, I need...
(surprise, motherfucker)
HEEEEY!!
WAAAH!!
FUCKING WHAT THE FUCK?!?
Why'd you do that???
That was completely unnecessary! I was taking my TIIIIME!!
Ohhhh, shitty dicks!
wAAAayYAYAYAY
OHYAYAYAY
OOOOOOOH
BOOM
MEAAAUH
This didn't go shit-where!!!
wHEUYH
I can't go anywhere!!
Oh, fuck,
this was a bAAAD IDEA!!
Oh my god
ohmygodohmygodohmygodohmygod
WHUYHHH
Crippy crawly
CRIIIIIIPPY CRAWLY
okherewego
I don't know where I'm going!
Oh, I'm going over this way apparently!
WOAH
HEY!
Don't do that!
Ya frickin' son of a bitch over there!
Okay!
Okay, we seem to be fine...
I don't even know why we went in that house,
if it was just going to be filled with DEATH, but okay..
Ugh, just a trap!
Two doors didn't do shit up against Nick!
eugh
He's too stRAUNg-
Oh, this seems safe!
Okay!
I'm gonna trust my life to this precarious perch!
OOOOohhh
That's the opposite of good!
HMM,
Is there a message on that arrow??
Alright, I'm gonna keep truckin' along,
hopefully no cacti are gonna get in my way.
HEYYY
OW!
GOD
DAMMIT!
God damn you!
Fine.
You wanna be like THAT,
YOU SACK O' SHIT?!?
HAH?
See how good a shot you are when I am...
BOOKIN' IT!
OOoh missed me,
bEeEEASCHH!
There's a cactus, BUT
DAUODGED!
HAHAHA!
Okay.
RunrunrUNRUNRUN
DOOOOODGE!
Ha-ha, missed me!
RunrunrUNRUN-
DOOOOdge.
uh oh
Noooo...
I'm gonna go with nooo!
Ooh boy.
Oh hi.
You're just waitin', aren't ya?
You're just waitin'!
(growling with head-shaking)
(more growling and head-shaking)
I'M SO GRUMPYYY
AT THE WOOORLD
For making me this hideously ugly.
Okay, but you carry on, I'm gonna go up here!
Seems like a good place to go.
Again, it's telling me I need to peek from a ledge, but I don't know-
BWAAAAAlrighty then!
He's gonna start a forest fire at this range.
YOOOOOOBADOOBADOOBADOOBADOOBA
AND daoooudge!
Nice.
Ooh, that guy is full of arrows!
Alrighty then.
SHOOBBIDOOBIDOOBIDOOBOODOOBI
DOOOODGE
OWWW!!
FUCKING- OW!
DOODGE!!
WHAT?!?!
He got smart and started aiming for my legs?!
Well, I gotta hippidyhop over those BOWS!
Alright, fine then.
whAYYY-
no you don't.
Reload, bitch!
Huh?
woOOP
boink
SHOOPIDOOWOOP
BLIP-BLOP
SCHPLEEP-SCHPLORP
C'mon,
do it,
HIT ME!
HIIT ME!
AAAAAAAH
wooh
okay.
shOOOO
(arrow'd)
OW!
That one hurt.
Aaah, but I'm alright!
I'm alright, I can pick it up from here.
(chuckles) Even though these guys didn't seem to pick it up very good.
Alright, but I can take this and this is gonna help me get along,
'cause apparently he's getting more accurate,
he's going for the KILLLLL!
Oh, your crucifix wasn't good enough?
Huuh?
HEYYY-
FUCKING- WHAT the FUCK?!
Ooow!
alright
wUUUHAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAUH
WIGGLY WIGGLY
wiggly wiggly
Too bad your...
...muscles are all melting, bitch!
whUAT THE FUCKing hell?!
woahwoah
The fuck is in here?
Wait, there's something in here!
Ow!
What the fuck is THAT?
Okay, I KIIIIIIIIAAAAAaaaaaaaaaaa...
I thought there was something in there...
It SEEMED like there was gonna be a secret in there..
and I went for it being all stupid-like...
not trusting what I was doing.
Alright, whautever.
At least we didn't lose any progress there, it seems.
Alright.
Ooh, cactiiii! Delicious!
Painfullll!
Alright.
And I don't know what it was even he-
hEEEY
AAAAAAOOOW!
AAAAAow!
Jesus, this poor son of a bitch!
Oh!
Well, that's not a good thing!
You were just shooting arrows at me!
Why should I be comforted by that?
I don't know if I SHOULD...
I don't even have my camera up, dude!
Ohhhh boy.
Do I have any objection to this?
Can I actually say no to this??
Or is this kind of a- kind of a 'expected of me' thing?
Cause I don't know what the sainted...
this tainted sainted...
taint-sainted...
taint-saintered...
I don't know what-HEYYYYY!!
Yeah, please don't.
PLEASE don't!
Pleeease
don't.
Yeah, they're gonna do it anyway.
YUP,
they're crazy, alright.
I can't do anything, I can't even move.
Alright, I'll be here!
Under the dirt!
All comfy in my...
dirt cLOOooOthes!
You take care of yourself now,
you take care of yourself!
I'll be here..
again...
under the GROUND,
dead.
Alright, oh!
Can I do something now?
Oooooh.
Uhhh,
yep, still in pain.
Oh, hands still hurt, slappin' my meat...
against that wood doesn't do much.
Oh boy.
eYH
Come on!
c'mON
c'moN
c'mon-whOAHH
Well, they don't do a very good job at this shit!
Wha- the- Really? That's it?
That's all it takes?
Man, they need to...
put a guard on me or something.
At this point I'm rooting for THEM because...
man, he's- thi-ti- this isn't exactly FAIR!
Alright, fine then.
We'll play it that way.
Did I document my own- whoa.
Heeey, c'mon now, don't be like that.
Don't be like that saAAAAAAAaaH
AUHAAAUHAAAUHAAA
EYEYEYEY
HEEEY
eyeyey
Doooon't do that!
I don't..
(hastily reads note)
(gives up completely)
beCAUSE FIBLEHBLEHBLEHBLEHBLehbleh!
I don't know what that said, I didn't have time to read it, this guy is slapping his way towards me!
Uuuuuuugh,
he's so slaaaaappy!
Whyyyyyy?
uUUUEEGh
Why do they all gotta be so
gROOOOSSsssss?
And disgustingly slappy?
Okay, so...
I wish I had time to pause and rest, but I don't.
So I'm gonna review my footage later.
OHHHH NOOO THEY'RE EVERYWHERE
UUUUH THEY'RE EVERYWHERE
Oh, there's no getting away from these guys.
WOAH!
AHH GODDAMMIT!!
aaaAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAHHHH!!!
I CAN'T make you clean, you're too dirtyyy!!!
HUEH
DOOO
SKEEEEE
Alright, fine then.
Where am I now?
Where did I run off to?
Oh boy.
Ohhh boy.
Oh, here we go!
I still hear em' slappin' behind me,
so I can only assume they're crawling through the same gap that I came through...
Unless their meat is just gonna fall of their bones there.
Yeeeesh.
Alright, seems like I got some respite.
Alright!
Oooh, hello!
(reads note)
(skips to end)
Okay, so this is why Laird was all kinds of, uh...
obsessed with making sure that he fulfilled the prophecy,
but HEY!
I think Laird said I was beautiful!
(indeed)
Yeah, definitely.
Okay, so what have I got here?
I wanna review this.
Let's see, "Gospel of the Saint..." okay
Aaaaah, clean text, huh?
Okay, what've we got here?
How bout' this?
(creepy distorted whispers)
Huh.
M'kay- OH I missed some, okay!
Wooow!
I did!
Crazy.
What is this?
(laughs)
A deformed toddler! Ah okay, yeah sure, alright, eh yeah, that's what it was.
Eeeugh.
(more distorted whispering)
Yeah, I can't make sense of any of these jarbled ones, but-
Oh, the locusts.
Was I recording that?
(apparently yes)
UUUGH!
EHHHHH!
(grossed-out Markiplier noises)
WHA- Eugh, gross!
Man, this POOR GUY,
he just gets beaten to SHIT every single place he goes!
Wow, aren't you scientific?
Oh, you know your shit, don'tcha? Okay.
Ah boy.
Yeah,
I might agree on that one.
Ohhh.
Yeah, I think I cried out for that before.
Didn't quite work out that way, but I seemed to have missed some stuff.
YEAH, IT'S NO GOOD!
I don't know what you're doing!
What are you talking about, "You should have loved me"?
What does that even mean?
ahh
The magic.
(Mark's grossed out again)
(yup, still grossed out)
(still)
You couldn't have what?
HELPED?!
TALKED to her?!
I guess I didn't try, so maybe that's my fault.
Jeezus.
(kind of a bad place to say that, don't you think?)
Yeah, sure.
(again with the grossed-out sounds)
Groooooss, okay.
Jeeeez.
Eugh.
Man, this is so weird, going back into what I did.
HUH?!
Who you talkin' about?!
AWWWWW NOO!
AWWWWWW
AW ISSO SAD
Don't remind me of the dead birds! AWW!
(jumpcut) Weird, okay.
So I gotta go back- so this is all in the beginning, so...
I'm gonna just-
I'm gonna make sure that I review any footage that I see thus far,
and make sure that I try to get everything possible because...
I started missing stuff when I was fiddling with the camera,
but I think now I'm getting more and more of everything-
(interrupting scream of agony)
Well, there's no need for that!
There's no need for ANY of that!
You can just STOP!
That's always an option, you can just stop!
Ohh, hello!
What am I lookin' at?
Oooh, hi!
oOoh, hi, why?
Ohh, you seem alive.
Ooookay...
Maybe not..
Oh boy.
Alrighty then, I'm gonna review this one,
(once more unto the gross)
just as a lesson to what I'm doing here.
What???
Wait-
Yeah, who are you talking about??
Yeah, you're talking about Jessica, aren't you?
You are!
This guy's brain is getting scrambled up-
I mean,
he is in unimaginable pain...
which just goes to show that maybe he's, uhhh...
not doing too well these days, so...
Honestly, who knows?
Hohhh boy...
It is not going well...
But at least he can get through this nightmare...
in one piece.
Ha ha, that's a laugh.
He's not gonna get through this in one piece at ALL!
Even gets to this- through this...
through this in the beginning.
Jesus.
Okay.
So- UUuuhh...
This is a convenient place-
BLUP
Barely, okay.
Glad I held onto my camera with that one.
Ohh, what do we got here?
(reads suicide note)
Okay. Are y- is this the guy that was just out there??
Like- man! All these events are transpiring immediately now.
Like!
IMMEDIATELY now.
They are happening right now.
That letter that I read in the church...
got a reply that I read down here,
so it can't have been... that far behind!
Uh, yeah you can, you big baby!
DO IT!!
(Blake dies instantly)
(sudden_regret.exe initiated)
I needed a rope... (OH NO SHIT SHERLOCK)
and uhhhhh...
now I know where I need that rope.
Okay.
I've fallen off of mountains before, you think that's gonna stop me-?
Oh, there's a gap to go above it..
Yeah, sure, can't take the actual door..
Gotta go-OHH!
You don't have to actually tell anybody that I'm here,
that's NOT okay!!
Goddammit, these spoil-sports!
Alright, fine. What are you gonna do about it?
Oh geez.
Can you sto- OHH.
hEY -OH OH
OH HI!
OHHHH HI!
I didn't know you were actually there!
WUEHEYEYYUEH
No thank you!
I've already been on the cross; I don't need to be there again!
oooOOOOOHH!
Ohhh boy, oh boy, oh boy!
Oh boy-oh boy-
jumpjuMPJUMPJUmpjump!
Here we go! Here we go! Herewego!!!
'Round and 'round the rosey-rose...
Here we goo!!
WOOBIDOOOOO!
WIBBIDIBOOBOOOO!
Okay-
Oh, this place is occupied!
Anything in there? No.
okay
OH HI!
Okay.
Bye then..!
I guess we're fine...?
Supposedly...
euugh
Alright- OHHhhh
aAAAHHhhhhh
Ahh, good, the roooooope!
Yeah, don't-
don't... don't untie the knot or anything...
THAT'S the better option.
Alright, fine then. Well, that happened.
Okay, so where's the body?
Where'd the body go??
Somewhere over here.
OHHHHhhhh nooooooooo.
Ooooh noooo.
OHHHH
noooo.
Heh- yeah, thanks!
(creeped-out laughter)
Yeeeeh- oh, hi.
Nahnonono!
Nononono...
You don't know I'm here do ya?
You're just a b- HEYYYY
ohh
GOD!!!
OHGODOHGOD
Nonononononononono
nunu
NUUUU
nunununu
Stop.
AH
shOOOOOHOOHOOHOOHOO
That was a close one,
I could even see that flying towards me.
Whoa!
HeyhEYHEYHeyhey!
NO need for that!
Jesus.
They shouldn't have TOLD ON ME!
Oh boy, he's REAL close.
Okay, yeah, you keep yellin' at your own guys...
Uh oh, he doesn't know I'm here...
I think I can go around this one!
rrrrAYYYaa-
OH HI!
HEY HEYHEYHEYHEYAYAYAYAY
D D D D D D D!
Get outta here!
Point me in the right direction, please, thank you!
Alright, we're gonna go we're gonna go we're gonna go we're gonna go we're gonna g-
THIS is not the correct way!!
OHHHH we're gonna go!!
OHHHHH BOY!
OHH BOY
ohboyohboyohboy
ya- NNOOOOO!!
URRRREEEEEEGH!!
c'mon c'mon c'mon
HIBIDIBOOSKI!
Alright, j- NOOO!
PUT THAT- NO!
Put- YETH!
That! That one!
Okay, good!
GOOO
PLEAAASE
GOOOOOOO!!
Uuuugh,
this ASSHOOOLE!
UUGH, this damn ass-
Oh?
What??
WHAT?!?
Why'd they do that???
Why'd they DO that?????
Why- why did they do that?!
OHH!
Hi!
How are you?
Oh, you don't look so good.
Uh-
Y'alright there buddy?
Nah??
Y'okay????
Nahh???
Okay.
Naaah!
Yeah, he not so good.
Let me review this one..
Oh yeah.
Okaaay...?
I don't see what that has to do with my SICK zooming action over there,
so maybe you could pay more attention to what's actually going on in front of your face.
JeezUUUUMS!
Fine!
Fine then!
If you wanna... be a big dumb doofy-doo about it.
Okay, how do I...?
w- where am I g-...?
what am I doing?
OH! Okay! Alright, this is a thing!
Holy SHIT!
(sudden realization) NOOOOO!
(kerclunk)
WAI- NOOOOOO!!
Yeah, you don't know where you are, do you?
I mean, then again, I don't know where he is,
but he doesn't know where he is
because his mind is breaking...
due to some unseen influence...
in this town.
Ooh.
Hi.
How you doin' over there?
So if THIS is the influence that it's having on this guy,
who has ONLY been here...
just a little bit...
I mean, even though he has demons,
of course he- ohhHEEYYYY!!
(Marki-sigh)
Ooohhhhhh noooo...
OHHH NOOOOO...
OHHHH noooo...
I don't like the fake footprints bullshit!
I mean, it's not fake,
that grabby-hands man is all over the place!
I just don't LIKE IT!!
Ohhh, good, of course, that's a good effect,
okay.
Let's hop this...
Yeah, we're good here.
Jeezums!
Now, THIS area reminds me of the original Outlast.
When you were wandering the courtyards and you were trying to find your way through all the fenced areas,
because for SOME REASON...
that was a VERY fenced asylum...
and they did not want NOOObody goin' NOwhere.
Oh boy. (you've said that a lot)
But this reminds me of that.
God...
Ah, b- but that's the interesting thing!
I have not...
drawn too many conclusions, o-or...
or like, uh...
correlations between THIS...
and the original Outlast,
and I'm actually kind happy for that, because this makes-
I mean, with the same elements of the camcorder and whatnot,
but it makes the story...
kinda this unique experience that...
like, it's new and interesting,
and I actually like that,
and I haven't had a chance to actually talk about the game from a game standpoint...
for a while now, but e-
OOOOOOOoooooooooohhhh...
hoooooooookaaaaaaayyy...
Uuuuugh!
oOHHHHH
oh- OHHH!!
MMMOHHHHHYOKAY!!
OHHHH DO I JUST-...
IS HE JUSUSUSUSUSOKAY?!
THAT'S JUST THE WAY IT IS NOW!!
OH GOD!!!
(you are ded)
(not big surprise)
Alright then.
Cooooool.
Yeaaaaah!
Ch'yah, duuuude! Ch'yah!
Alriiiight, okaaay!
Ch'yaaaaah, riiiiiiight!
Fucking, just-
what i- th-
what is that supposed to be?
UUUUUGH NO NONOnononononoNOno
Okay, so they come from top AND below...
but I didn't see THIS guy,
I was lookin' the other way!
Ohhh boy!
'Kay, you gonna be up there now-?
OHHHHHHH
it's not two, it's OOOOONE!
Okay, alright!
You gonna be down here?
You gonna be down here? No?
Yes- HEY!!
OH
GOD!!!
(more ded)
I didn't know he was gonna be running.
I didn't know it was gonna be a running kind of thing.
Ahhh, I was not prepared...
(laughs to self)
I wasn't prepared for that at ALL,
no no no, I was NOOOOT.
I was NOT-
Okay, you're down there...
okay, and then you're gonna be up here...
and then I'm gonna run back down...
not be a big dumb idiot...
YYRRRREY!
oOOOoOoOoOoOoOoOoOoOOohhh!
Alrighty then!
BOOOOM!
Am I okay?
Jesus, I bet they didn't expect anybody to die there TWICE!
Like an idiot!
UUUUGH!
Okay, I just got the weirdest flashback to, uh...
to a game very few of you are gonna actually remember,
but some of you is the first experience to my channel-
I just got a-
flashback to Slender: Elementary...
Do you guys remember that one? (yes)
Yeah!
Yeah...
Eh, not particularly well-made,
but it was when those Slenderman's Shadow series were being made, and...
and I just got a-
I just caught a wind of it somehow.
Super weird, but I love it!
Oh man.
Hope you guys aren't drowning in nostalgia at this point.
(I am)
Wha- is he done?
It's locked!
Okay, where do I go?
Oh!
Ohhhhhhh-
no, I just went through there!
It can't- it doesn't open!
So where do I go?
(jumpcut)
Uh oh.
What the fuck is happening?
Oh!
THIS one!
Oh, okay! That would've been...
That was a little difficult to point out!
Uuuuuuuugh...
Okay, hi!
Hello!
(squeeeak)
Helloooo?
Hello?
Ohhh, they ca-
tha- that- that hallway looks bad,
this hallway looks...
I mean, also bad because it goes nowhere, but-
Okay, I'll take this option!
With the DARK, SCARY HALLWAY and the-...
uuuuuuuuuUUUUUAAAAAAAAHH!!
OOOOOOAAAAYYH!!
oohhhhhh- NU!!
NO!!
NO!!!
Okay, alright...
okay- I RAN THE WRONG WAY!!!
MMMMMAAAArrahh!
Good GOD!
Don't do that to me!
Frick-a-dick, I'm not that bad at games!
(kerclank)
OHHHHhhhhhh...
Monday, Tuesday, Wednesday, Thursday...
Criday???
Okay...
Breaaaaakfas-
Is that how you make an F?
Oh, it's the cursive F!
Ohhh, that's stupid.
You're stupid.
Think they got tons of green beans.
Alright,
I don't know if I wanna go that way,
I don't know if I wanna go THIS way-
Alright, I guess you're...
removing all choice from me-
but I'm making my way...
further and further through the school.
I DO notice that I'm in the exact same school I...
start out in...
every single time, and I'm just making my way through...
the entire environment.
I'm not necessarily making any, like...
NEW revelations here, it's all the same place.
Uhhhhhh,
"Don't let me go,"
I- I think that's the same one that was there before.
Wasn't i-
(spoopy interruption)
boOOOOOOOoooooOOOOOOOHHHHHH!
IS THAT GOOD OR BAD?
'S THAT GOOD OR BAD?
THAT GOOD OR BAD?
Okay, that looks good!
I LIKE that!
AHH!
HI!
I didn't quite get that, okay? Can you...
Oh...
Oh-
th-
there's no-
But I didn't get that!
For some reason I didn't have my camera up!
(too bad, so sad)
Hello?
uh oh...
Uh oh.
Oh, I don't like that.
Hiiiiii!
Oh hiiiiii!
Oh, can you stop that, please?
Oh, s- PLEASE stop tickling my ear with your horror sounds.
Oh, here we go!
Ohhhh...
Ohhh...
Uh huh...
(scared hiss)
(boo)
AAAAAAEEEE!!!
(twitch)
Okay!
oKAY!
Alright!
Not cool, but okay!
Hello?
Oh, okay- oh- OHHHH!
OHHHHHHH!
Ahhhhhh!
Gooooood!
How did I make it here...
from...
wherever the hell I was?
Oh my god!
How is this happening?
Like, either ALL of this is an illusion,
like in The Evil Within, OR...
I am in some sort of a fugue state that just so hhhhHAPPENS...
to coincidate with the actual world.
And yes, coincidate... is not a real word in any...
it's not- it's not a real word,
in any capacity.
Jeezums!
But have I made it to the goddamn mines yet?
I think I've gotten sidetracked ENOUGH!
Oh, what is that?
Uuuugh!
Really?
Is that-
is that- is thaaaat how it is?
It's that easy?
Not so easy when you're flippin' in and out of this dimension, huh, buddy?
Stop- doing that! Goddammit!
You'd think that they would just let the camera be glued to your face!
I mean, why would you have the option of putting it down if you're ONLY supposed to go through the game...
with it up?
Or at least, it seems like it's that way.
Alright, here we go.
Helloooo!
Oh, hi...
Uhhhh...
Okaaaaay!
Whatever you say!
You know I'm now going to put my toes... in that water.
Ohhhh, that looks wrong...
Oh, that looks VERY wrong!
eeEUUUUUUUUGH!
What am I looking at?
What am I looking at??
The water?
Mmmmm, it don't look...
(mega zoom) GOOD!
Got it.
Nailed it.
Nabbed it!
Let's do this!
Huh, dead things?
LIKE ME??
Like Jessica, I guess.
Oooohh.
No, okay.
N-ah, I can't believe I missed that!
Dammit, I wanted to get that.
HOOOOOP CANNONBAAAAAALL!
Cannon- cannonball???
I'm gonna swim for it!
Apparently this is working...
for so-
Oh?
Uuhhh!
Uh!
I can't put my camera up anymore!
Oh, there we go!
Apparently!
Why am I just here?!
W-HEEYYYY!!
Oooookay...
OOH!
Hello!
AAAYyyyyyyyy, what the fuck?
That was Grabby-Hands!
And that was that voice on the phone!
Ahhhhhhhh,
okay.
Maybe they're one and the same, you know what I'm sayin'?
Ehhhhh.
Yeah, why?
Is that 'cause Grabby-Hands just went underneath?
But that guy looked like he might have been a priest,
which makes me THINK...
that something happened with those... priests,
at the school that he grew up in.
And I don't wanna go the cliché route,
but it seems to me that MAYYYYBE just maybe...
somethin' bad happened. (no shit)
You know what I mean?
(I know what you mean)
I don't wanna- I don't wanna be that guy, but-
Yeah, that seems to be the way that this is leaning towards,
and that caused Jessica to...
kill herself, I guess.
It's horrible.
Alright,
but I gotta find a way in here,
which I just did, I think.
WOAH okay,
alright then.
No?
Aw, come on!
Lemme IIIINNNN!
LEMME IIIIINNN!!
Oh, wait,
there's a place...
Ah.
There's a pit underground,
which means that there's a way to crawwwl...
in right here!
NNNOPE, this is a lie!
This is NOT the right way!
But I'm on the right track.
So there must be a way in from under here, maybe?
Nahhh?
There's gotta be a way in!
I know that for a fact-
oOOHHHhh, here we go!
Helloooooo!
I'm gonna crawl my way-
oop, nevermind,
no I'm not.
Okay, that was just a joke, I was just joking about that.
'S not true, I'm not gonna do that.
(jumpcut) Okay, I can't find a way in.
I wish I could, but I can't.
'Cause that window doesn't open,
and none of these places seem to lead to where I need to go...
and that's not open up there SO I guess I'm on my own, then.
So what do I need to do to be able to get through this lake-?
okay, thanks for stumbling!
There's gotta be, like, something here...
that's gonna help me.
And I don't know how they're fishin' with Mr. Grabby-Hands in there.
But that, again-
that, again, is IN MY MIND!
Right- and there's some screaming going on in the distance...
I don't know what THAT'S all about,
but maybe I can get in here.
NNNOPE!
But maybe these houses are connected!
Maybe I'd be able to get in that way.
NOOOPE, looocked.
These guys have some sturdy loooocks.
If only Nick and Laird were still alive,
then maybe I'd be able to get them to bash it open.
But unfortunately...
the answer to that seems to be no.
Alright, nothing yet.
OH, but I made it behind here!
Okay, so this is where I needed to go,
and now I need to get across the lake...
and so-
hopefully something up here is gonna help me-
Someone had a luxury mansion up-...
Hello?
Okaaay...
Whatever you say-
OOH NOt on that edge,
not on that edge.
Yeah-
AAAYYYYYY-
okay, that was me.
I don't know who's doing all this deck-building here,
because there are a lot-...
oooh
What am I looking at?
What?
What??
I don't see what you're talking about.
Oh, that?
oooooooh-
Power station?!
Is that what I'm looking at?
Oh, f- GODDAMMIT DON'T DO THAT!!
Goddammit, it's so easy to hit the GODDAMN BUTTON!!
Fuck, sorry about that.
It's so annoying.
(heavy sigh)
Alright, aaaaaaaand
boop!
What've we got to say about that one?
Hello?
Ah, okay.
Yeah, that is weird, because-
Heh!
Wait, what?
"For a second I was dumb enough to think I might not di-"
Wait, WHAT?!
Wait, that's not the state-th-ment you make after you see civilization!
HUH??
Wait, what???
And ALSO,
that is a stone's throw away...
from all of this insanity right here,
and there seems to be, like...
what are those, smokestacks?
Like, there's obviously a power substation,
and there's obviously...
a hell of a lot of contracting going on around here.
'Cause they need food-
I mean, they need SOME medicine for Papa Knoth, who's...
not practicing what he preaches,
and oh, that's a good place to jump off.
Not gonna do it, though.
(do it, you pussy)
Jeezums.
WHOOOP! (there you go)
It looks like the moment from, uh...
(ded)
OWWW, my bones!!
From, uh, Until Dawn,
right at the beginning of the game when they fall into that pit...
the sisters do, right at the beginning.
I wonder if it- YEAAAH!
Yeah, it b- it knew!
"What the fuck?"?
Oh, you're talking about that over there.
Oh, okay.
Not yet, big buddy.
Not yet; we got a lot more to explore over here.
Don't lose your mind yet!
Noooooot yet-
okay, here we go.
fooooo- SHOOPDEE!
(ouch)
Nailed it.
Slightly broken bones, but what else is new?
'Cause I've been IMPALED...
on, like, a FENCE!
I've been impaled on more than just a fence;
I've had NAILS driven through me,
I've fallen down...
SOOOO many times!
I survived a helicopter crash!
I am a broken man!
Or I SHOULD be anyway,
but apparently I'm made of steel,
and this is impossible to cross over.
Jeezu- Oh!
(confused Markimoo is confused)
UUHHHHH, is there something I should KNOW about?
Because you all ran away REAL quick,
and I don't like being left in the lurch...
with the red candles.
The red candles kinda signify the Heretic territory.
EGH!
Hello?
Hellooo?
Okay...
HellooOOO??
Ugh...
Yeah, so this must have been a Heretic place,
it kinda just all blends together!
Huh.
(reads note)
Sooooo,
why am I going DEEPER into this??
I mean, God, I just shouldn't have lost my wife!
Should've found these goddamn Heretics... (bad choice of words there)
LOOONG ago!
Huuuhhhhh...
alrighty then...
So there must have been some way to get into that house, but I just didn't see it!
Hello-?
OH GOOD, NO BOAT!
I'm gonna be No-boat-iplier here!
No luck, no boat!
Is that a dead body?
I bet it is!
ahh, frick all y'all...
Alright, carrying ooooon...
HOOOOOPDEE!
(kasmash)
OHHHH, WHY?!
WHY- WHO DID THAT?!
WHY???
Who did that and why?
Okayyyy...
Alright then...
Okaaaaaaay...
I'll take that, thank youuuuuu!
nnnNNEEEEEEEEGH
nnNNNNNEEEEEEEGH
Oh, what am I recording?!
Ohhhhhh-
That?
That??
WHAT AM I RECORDING?!
What am I looking at?
I never know what you're looking at!
Aaalrighty then.
Jeezums.
"Help"?
"HELP?!"
Where in the world did you read "help"??
I have NNO idea what he's talking about,
I have NNNO idea.
Jeezums...
Okay, but I'd better carry on the way that this- these guys went...
when they were running into the darkness, because...
there's gotta be something here.
right?
Oh, good, a cave!
ohhh...
Good, a dead end.
Where did they go, then?!
(reads note)
SO!
What that means is...
that's not just civilization!
Those are towers...
that are...
pumping out some sort of psychological signal,
that is messing with the population here!
Which means,
that...
maybe ALL of this...
What're you talking about?
What raft?
I don't see a raft.
Why do you keep saying things that I don't see?
But either way...
that means that those towers over there...
might be pumping out a signal-
or maybe not even THOSE towers.
That could just be a power substation that-
that powers them...
and the other ones that I saw...
right there...
Those might be the ones that are broadcasting something.
So I don't know what it all means,
but it looks like I've got the means of transportation to get across this lake,
but THAT'S going to have to wait until the next episode,
because I'm all out of time.
So thank you everybody so much for watching,
and pay attention...
to the weird humming sounds in the air...
(outro music starts) 'cause that may mean something.
So thanks again...
and as always,
I will see YOU...
in the next video!
Buh-byyyyye!
(outro)
(goddamn, that took me ALL DAY!)
(like, no joke, this took me a whole day to caption)
(but it was fun, not gonna deny)
(welp, see you next time!)